hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
what's your name chica I'm Alec has her
own YouTube channel you could check it
out also she is one of the leads in the
movie ice it's called ice the movie it's
about mr. freeze from Batman and Robin
no that's a weak joke let's keep it in
the video anyway it's a movie that she
co-stars in and you could check it out
right now you could buy it on Vimeo and
also it's gonna be on Amazon very soon
but if you want to get it right away and
show some support go check it out a
Vimeo there's a link in the description
box for you oh Lisa
YouTube has some original content once
in a while like they do YouTube bread
sometimes they do these like YouTube
movies and YouTube red shows right here
they have this movie called impulse all
it says is YouTube original I'm assuming
it's a YouTube red movie no idea who is
in its what it's about but hey let's
check it out
alright I'm ready headphones on my dear
20 years
I'm just really silky let's do it
from the director white Doug Liman did
this
he's the director of those movies
this is like a real movie yeah I know
Black Swan this is trippy it's creepy
[Music]
acid-base your father is not the person
that you think he is
Wow
oh my god I'm getting nervous really
strange like lost time
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh that's the end of the movie
right I wonder she hasn't helped a like
superpower
maybe it's her impulse she's doing
YouTube is throwing down on original
content for shows and movies I think she
probably has some like teleportation oh
it's a show
a young woman discovers she has the
extraordinary power of teleportation we
read that after just a super dork I mean
it probably is a dark show well this
makes sense of this the guy who directed
this actually did a movie called jumper
which was the guy who directed this I
mean he saw movies like Bourne Identity
mr. mrs. Smith a sci-fi like edge of
tomorrow we did one movie called jumper
which is about a guy who can teleport so
it makes sense that he would hop on to
something like this where I imagine he
has a lot more creative freedom it's a
ten episode series and he gets to do
this really dark thing what is the
YouTube read description say
sixteen-year-old Henry Cole's is an
outsider names Henry oh Henry okay
engineering for doing that these days
celebrities are naming their children
all sorts of stuff Newtown of rest in
New York with a major chip on our
shoulder and no French remains which
drawn an isolated but everything changes
when a traumatic encounter with a
classmate's triggers something deep
within Henry unleashing a power she
cannot control oh wow so this is an
interesting take on a superhero
likability it looks visually great and
I'm excited that YouTube was able to get
a director of that level up for stage in
that caliber of like Hollywood talent to
come on board for this YouTube original
series that was incredibly captivating
for sure I my heart was
pounding I'm like wait what's going on
you know but now that I see that it
around this power that makes it even
more yeah because at first I wasn't
entirely sure if it was just like
metaphorical or hypnotic dream sequences
but having to confirm that oh she does
have this teleportation power makes it a
lot more interesting to take them a more
characterization human approach to
someone who covers this ability someone
with trauma Marvel has been doing shows
I have like this teen angst type of
dramatic like superhero vibe and I think
they're kind of doing their own thing
but this feels a lot more like movie
like cinematic yeah it does I I wasn't
guessing a TV show as guessing a movie
it felt like a movie I thought it was
gonna be just a two-hour film it's crazy
to me how much YouTube and now like
already there's been Hulu Amazon and
Netflix for their original series with
YouTube doing they're doing bringing
back the Karate Kid on YouTube red and
now they're doing this I feel like they
are looking to truly compete now because
taking over the world kind of pretty
crazy what I'm curious about is this guy
did jumper and he wanted to make like a
trilogy out of it but the movie didn't
do so well oh so he never got to do the
sequel so I'm wondering if he's taking
any ideas from the sequels that he had
in mind in a plan yeah like recycle some
imight get a youtube read account now
just actually check this out it looks
good yeah I was surprised I'm not gonna
lie yeah but I will not underestimate
YouTube you should oh they make some
terrible YouTube reddit conscious you
guys subscribe you the real rejects
click that notification really get
notified every time one of our vids is
up and you could check out Lisa Melek on
YouTube as well and we have a patreon go
check us out over there and ice the
movie in the description box if watch
check it out
have you guys check it out tell her what
you think